let's rewind a little bit what we
established last lesson this morning was
that this is true the limiting some of
that series we define it as the limit as
n approaches infinity of all the partial
sums of this thing right and you get one
when you do that process when you think
not just with like adding and
subtracting and monkeying around which
we've seen is a very dangerous process
the way you deal with this infinity is
you introduce limits when you deduce
limits that's why we call this the
Lebanese son that's all fine okay one of
the things I pointed out was that it
looks as though one of the plausible
reasons why of limiting some does exist
for this thing is because every term as
you go to successive terms they're all
approaching zero
so if you want to think about it this
way let's let's go to that arm let's go
to that port frog that's dying out in a
desert or whatever okay because each
successive distance that gets added is
smaller and smaller and smaller it's
slowing down forever okay therefore it
seems to this is yes if I'm slowing down
forever there'll be some limit that I
can't get past right that is reasonable
logic the only problem is that it's dead
wrong okay now I'm going to prove that
to you I'm using this really important
result before I do it though I'm just
going to tease a little bit you guys
already have enough intuition and enough
mathematics to know that just because
something is slowing down and slowing
down forever that doesn't necessarily
mean that there's some upper limit at
which it stops you've already have
enough intuition enough mathematics to
know it I will remind you at the end
about what piece of all you already know
which tell you that this is not enough
this is insufficient but for now I'm
going to show you just really minik
aware okay I am going to show you the
harmonic series now we looked at the
alternating harmonic series of in while
ago and it was composed of these
fractions right 1/2 1/3
actually citing for that cooking start
with 101 1/2 1/3 1/4 1/5 and so those
are the fractions that made the
alternating harmonic series what made
that was alternating was the plus minus
plus ones yeah so this the regular
comedy series just has all pluses I
can't pay you right now I'm actually
going to write up a few more terms here
now this is the harmonic series okay
it fits this condition as n approaches
infinity the terms of progeria each
individual term okay but what happens to
the song is there a limiting sum is this
remember our two categories is it
convergent or is it divergent okay and
the proof for this is really marvelous
okay watch see this series okay this
series if all I want to do is prove that
it diverges which it does even though
this is true okay what I'm gonna do is
compare it with another series that I
can prove really easily is diverging
okay watch it's not good good if you
take this series okay I'm just gonna
write the I'm gonna write the first two
terms the same okay but for the
following terms I'm going to adjust the
terms just a little bit I'm making a
whole new series now okay but I'm going
to it's gonna have enough similarity to
this one that I can make a comparison
okay what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
place a third with a corner okay you're
like why are you doing that okay you
will see why in a second so I've
replaced this guy here
I said I'll replace it with a corner
okay and then the quarter stays the same
when I have a look at these terms here
I'm gonna replace one two three terms a
fifth a sixth and a seventh I'm gonna
replace all of them with an eighth like
so and hey hey
and ace and top up top and I can
continue this pattern forever right now
this is a new series this is not the
harmonic series but I want you to think
about how the humble issues relates to
this new one I've made right
notice these I'll just put them in
arrows these are the terms I've changed
most of the terms are the same at least
ones I've written but these ones I've
changed now my new series right you tell
me is this series bigger or smaller than
the harmonic series look again it must
be smaller do you see why it's smaller
you have look what's it it's the same
like these guys are the same these guys
are the same these guys are the same but
every term I've changed every time I've
changed I've made it smaller right the
corner is smaller than the third and a
is smaller than all of these turns right
so this new one is smaller in other
words the harmonic series the actual
harmonic series is bigger than this
series do you agree with that new series
smaller than the harmonic series okay
but become the power of on come at
brackets now okay
this new series that I made is very easy
to show that it's divergent okay
watch are you some of you might spot it
already I let these terms alone but I
changed this one the reason I changed it
was so I could group it with a club okay
why am I gonna do that well just watch
for a second why did I change these ones
all to 1/8 it was so that I could grip
them with this one it okay now having
gripped them in this way and you know if
I did the next term and have a 16 or 16
to 16 all the way up I have eight of
them okay what have I got now how can i
rewrite this bite by combining some of
my terms I can say now by the way no I
said combining I haven't changed the
order right we've seen changing order as
dangerous I haven't change yours all
fine and that first time is 1 second
term is 1/2 what's this equal to that's
a
this is for eight which is equal to
uh-huh
in fact every grouping that I make
subsequently I just I cannot be bothered
to write how many 16 zero and so on
they're all going to be a half every
single one okay this well ignoring the
one know anyone this is a GP with ratio
one right and we saw before there's
every we share one and it's pretty easy
to see this thing's gonna blow up isn't
it right the partial sum of this series
here is never gonna approach anything
it's gonna go 1/2 1 1 and a half to two
and a half it will get as big as you
want it doesn't converge to anything
okay so therefore he comes the logic
okay I'm sorry I would write this out
this is not necessarily a neat notation
winter since this right-hand side since
the right hand side of the inequality is
a divergent series or at least it has a
divergent series in it plus a 1 okay and
H is bigger than the right hand side
therefore H is also divergent because if
you're bigger than something that blows
up you're also going up okay so
therefore in what force it was shown
that this guy even though it gets
smaller and smaller and smaller smaller
it slows down as it were forever okay
because the partial sums they do the
gaps between them get progressively
smaller okay but it never stops at
anything
there's no point at which I can say
here's my limit there's no you can't go
any further than this if you pick a
number like say R hundred okay if you
give the harmonic series long enough you
don't get there if you say a million if
you give the harmonic series long enough
you don't get there okay
now I said just before I starred in any
of this right that you have enough
mathematics and enough intuition to know
actually but even if this is sure
for an example like this that doesn't
mean it converges you already know about
a kind of function that grows in exactly
this way that slows down and slows down
and slows down forever but it has the
limit and the answer is the log function
is now square the square roots also do
that it's also do that but I'm really
glad someone mentioned walks because
little ones look like right they look
like this roughly okay what's really
really crazy if I say this is y equals
natural log of X okay so that would be
if I had a value like that would get one
the partial sums if you take s1 s2 s3 s4
of the harmonic series right if I put
this if I actually plot this I'm going
to get values that are about what's the
number well the first one is one in fact
you color the harmonic series as it
turns out is exactly the same as the log
curve and it's only off by a constant
right in fact that's one of the
definitions of the logarithmic curve it
comes from the harmonic series okay this
isn't just like it it is a logarithmic
function which is crazy but the
logarithmic function as you know there's
no limits right if you want to really
really high number up here you just need
a sufficiently large X and you get there
okay so this is a is a famous people I
can't I do write down which would be
silly do write down the name of the
person who first devised it but it's
great because it combines things you
already know it's so short it's so short
and it talks in terms of things that are
actually really important to the course
namely I think it's convergent things
divergent how do you know